let's go back to the early days what did
the formation of the Milky Way galaxy
look like or maybe we want to start even
before that what did the formation of
the universe look like
well we scientists believe that was the
Big Bang some big beginning
but what is important for my work and I
think that's what we're going to talk
about is what kind of elements were
present at that time
so the Big Bang left a universe behind
that was made of just hydrogen and
helium and tiny little sprinkles of
lithium
and that was pretty much it
and as it turns out it's actually quite
hard to make stars or any structure from
that that's fairly hot gas
and so the very first stars that formed
prior to to any galaxies were very
massive stars big stars 100 times the
mass of the Sun and they were made from
just hydrogen and helium so big stars
explode pretty fast after a few million
years only that's very short on Cosmic
time scales
and in their explosions they provided
the first heavier elements to the
universe because in that course All
Stars fuse lighter elements like
hydrogen helium into heavier ones
and then that goes all the way up to
iron and then all that material gets
ejected in these massive Supernova
explosions and that marked a really
really important
um transition in the universe because
after that first explosion
it was no longer chemically pristine
and that's at the stage for everything
else to happen including us here talking
today so what do you mean by pristine so
there's a whole a complex soup of
elements now as opposed to just hydrogen
helium and a little bit of lithium yeah
so after the big bang just hydrogen and
helium we don't really need to talk too
much about lithium because the amount
was so small
um and after these very first stars
formed and exploded they the heavier
elements like carbon oxygen magnesium
iron all of that stuff was was suddenly
present in the gas clouds uh in tiny
amounts only very tiny amounts but and
that actually helped especially the
carbon and the oxygen to to make the gas
cool these atoms are more complicated
than hydrogen that's just a proton and
so it has cooling properties can send
out photons outside of the gas cloud so
the gas can cool and when you have gas
that that gets colder and colder you can
make smaller and smaller Stars so you
can fragment it and Clump it and turn it
into stars like like the sun and the
cool thing about that is that
when you have small stars like the sun
they have a really long lifetime so
those first low masters that formed back
then are still observable today
that is actually what I do I try to find
these early survivors
because they tell us
what the gas looked like back then they
have preserved that composition of these
early gas cloud the chemical
compositions until today so I don't need
to look very far into the universe to
study all the beginnings I can just
chemically analyze the oldest stars and
it's like unpacking everything that that
happened back then it's very exciting so
to just reiterate so in the very early
days in the first few million years
there's giant Stars that's mostly
hydrogen helium and then they exploded
in these Supernova explosions and then
they made these clumps
pristine clumps yeah pretty much fun so
it took a few hundred million years for
the first stars to emerge yes and then
they exploded after a few million years
Kaboom and then it's like I always
consider the universe like a you know a
nice soup and then these first Supernova
explosions kind of provided the salt you
know just a little sprinkle of heavier
elements and that made it really tasty
it's just changed it completely right
and that changed the physics of the gas
so that meant that these these gas
clouds that were you know surrounding
the the Forma first Stars they could now
cool down and Clump and form the next
generation of stars that now included
also little stars
and um as I just mentioned the small
stars have these really long lifetimes
the sun has a lifetime of 10 billion
years
any star that is even less massive will
have an even longer lifetime
so that gives us a chance to to still
observe some of the stats that form back
then so we are testing the the
conditions of chemical and physical
conditions of the early Universe even
before the Galaxy formed so what's the
timeline that we're talking about what
is the age of the universe and what is
the earliest time we got those salty
delicious soup Clump soups with heavier
elements
well the universe is 13.8 billion years
old but legitly yeah
when I was in high school the universe
was 20 billion years old oh yeah so the
estimate did that changed do you think
that estimate will evolve in interesting
ways or no is that is it I think it's
mostly converged yes because the
techniques are very different now much
more precise um the whole business of
precision cosmology by mapping out the
cosmic microf background you know that
that's a marvelous feat
um maybe you know the digits will still
move around a little bit but that's all
right plus the gravitational waves and
all that's all the different sources of
data yeah kind of mapping out this
detailed picture of the early Universe
yeah totally and so we think the
earliest little stars formed I don't
know maybe half a billion years after
the big bang right again a few hundred
million years for the first stars to
emerge and then you know took some time
so give or take half a billion years and
um that was the time when sort of the
very first pro photo galaxies formed
early Stella structures Stella systems
from which the Milky Way eventually
formed right so it was the Mickey was
probably a bigger slightly bigger one
and we know today that galaxies grow
hierarchically which means they eat
their smaller neighbors so if you're the
bigger one and have a few a few friends
around you're just gonna
um eat them absorb them and then you
grow bigger and
um so all these these little early Stars
you know kind of came into the Mickey
way through that kind of process
and that's why we find them in the outer
parts of the Galaxy today because
they're just kind of deaf and just left
there since so the old stuff is on the
outskirts of the Galaxy and the new
stuff is in closer to the middle is
there broadly speaking okay yes